les relations économiques entre la Chine
et les États-Unis selon beaucoup de de
critères les deux premières puissances
économiques mondiales sont pour les deux
tiers régies les relations commerciales
sont pour les deux tiers régies par des
règles qui ne sont pas conformes à leurs
engagement internationaux étant donné la
guerre commerciale de Trump qui est dans
les les droits enfin disons les mesures
restent en place c'est une situation
dans laquelle les aides publiques aux
entreprises sont aujourd'hui absolument
massifs dans beaucoup de secteurs et là
aussi clairement non conformes aux
engagements qui avaient écrit prises qui
avaient été pris dans le cadre des
engagements multilatéraux on peut penser
à la Chine dont une estimation récente
très probablement sous-estimé montrent
que la politique industrielle mobilise
plus de 1,7% du PIB lors de grandeur en
France c'est un peu plus de 0,5 en
Allemagne aux États-Unis 04
on peut penser évidemment aux lois
récente américaine
et évidemment plus récemment une flèche
qui y compris inclut des dispositions
discriminatoires dans les aides qui le
met à la disposition des entreprises
l'Union européenne elle-même est plus
timide mais elle avance également dans
ce dans cette dimension et il faut
souligner que dans beaucoup de cas au
niveau mondial on se retrouve avec des
secteurs pour lesquels l'ordre de
grandeur des subventions est massif